él cree que a estas alturas Hay
posibilidades de que el actual
mandatario no reconozca los resultados
de estas elecciones
Hola buenas tardes a todos
Bueno él Da señales de que puede nos
reconocer no me parece que es muy
difícil que hablemos de un golpe de
estado pero el presidente nos Da señales
de que vamos si no gana las elecciones
vamos a tener una transición bastante
complicada en Brasil
y precisamente no el ultraderechista
bolsonaro y el izquierdista Lula da
Silva representan puntos Opuestos en el
espectro político al margen de lo que
pueda suponer su elección dentro de
Brasil en el país que puede suponer en
términos de alianzas regionales e
internacionales la elección de uno o de
otro
bueno Brasil tiene viene teniendo en los
últimos cuatro años de relaciones
muy débiles con América Latina por
ejemplo teníamos relaciones muy muy muy
consolidadas en los gobiernos anteriores
y pasemos a tener graduaciones muy
débiles y el actual presidente no nos Da
señales de que va a profundizar estas
relaciones Si gana en cambio Lula da
Silva Pues siempre ha tenido un intento
de relacionarse muy bien con América
Latina y se supone que si regresa al
poder va a intentar restablecer las
relaciones Sur que Brasil ya tenía en
sus dos gobiernos anteriores
cambiemos ahora de enfoque porque por la
extrema polarización sobre todo entre
los principales candidatos como decíamos
a Lula y bolsonaro hemos centrado mucho
la atención en las presidenciales en
esta primera vuelta pero cómo puede
afectar a la gobernabilidad del país el
resultado de las legislativas
claro Brasil hoy elige 513 diputados
federales y 27 senadores y Bueno es muy
importante un país con tantos partidos
políticos tener un legislativo que ayude
el presidente de la república gobernar
no Entonces
no vamos Parece ser que nos vamos a
tener cambios muy significativos en el
legislativo no nos lleva a creer que
vamos a tener legislativo bastante
pulverizado como tenemos hoy con muchos
partidos no Y eso pues va a jugar un
papel muy importante en la
gobernabilidad de los presidentes
cualquier cualquier análisis más
profundizado pues vamos a tener al fin
del día de hoy para saber cómo está
conformado el congreso nacional y como
este congreso va a poder jugar con un
presidente o con el otro presidente
dependiendo de quién gane estas esta
jornada electoral en Brasil
y Michelle para cerrar un poco con los
escenarios que están abiertos a esta
hora que recordemos todavía no conocemos
a los resultados de esta jornada
electoral en Brasil a pesar de que
acaben de cerrar las urnas que
escenarios estarían abiertos de Cara a
una posible segunda vuelta a finales de
octubre y Cuáles serían los factores que
ambos candidatos deberían movilizar de
acuerdo con las últimas encuestas de
ayer Ayer tuvimos tres encuestas el Lula
da Silva saliendo del 48 hasta el 51% de
de votos de votos válidos no y tenemos
que tener un 50%
más un voto para ganar internet primera
vuelta es decir Hay una posibilidad de
que la elección presidencial se termine
hoy pero no es el resultado más probable
no el resultado más probable es que
tengamos una segunda vuelta Bueno al
final del día de hoy ya ya vamos a hacer
ya tenemos un nuevo presidente de la
república o si vamos a tener que esperar
hasta finales de octubre para elegir el
presidente de